Ghostwriter. He’s back.
In three, two, one.
Whoa.
I thought moving here and starting
a new school would be hard.
But I found friends I
never imagined I’d find.
Chevon.
Curtis.
And Donna.
It changed everything.
There’s a logical explanation.
It’s a ghost.
I think the ghost can only
communicate with written words.
The ghost writer?
Do you have the time?
There’s a talking rabbit that
nobody can see but us.
I think the rabbit from
this book has escaped.
Who let him out?
The ghost who’s been
sending us messages.
What is this?
What are you doing?
Horrifying.
What if your grandma’s ghostwriter?
Grandpa said even though grandma’s
gone she’ll always be with us.
Like a ghost.
And they only hang around when
they have unfinished business.
Let’s do this.
Your grandma had this old letter.
Secret letter?
It must’ve been important.
We need to find that letter.
Ghostwriter let the characters out of the book.
Grandma wouldn’t have sent them here
unless they were important to the mystery.
Grandma’s letter.
Who’s “S”?
The mystery is nowhere
close to being solved.
I’m pretty good at solving mysteries.
Sparkles, they’re memories
left behind by other people.
That’s my grandma.
There was a weird guy that gave
a check to grandma and it was
inside the Mason Briggs book.
That’s grandma’s letter.
So that person is “S.”
But who is it?
We need to find him.
That lady that used to work here…
My grandma.
She was sure that this
bookstore was haunted.
If my grandma’s not Ghostwriter, then
who have we been talking to all this time?
Ghostwriter wasn’t releasing your paintings.
The character in this case
would be the paint brush.
Cobalt Mask.
The painting.
There’s no author. That’s a first.
Frank is from a poem.
He’s a spy.
He’s also from a bunch of
Mason Briggs books.
Mason Briggs wrote detective fiction.
At which point he drops off the map.
The Cobalt Mask never came out.
And he has an unpublished manuscript.
Mason Briggs has to be involved
in the mystery somehow.
Sherlock Holmes.
Doctor Watson?
We need help solving a case.
Let the facts lead you.
Mason Briggs is a pseudonym.
This photo allowed us to
find the real Mason Briggs.
This technology is fantastic.
No kidding, Sherlock.
If we find this view, we find the manuscript.
Look!
Nice view.
Check this out.
We’re so close to finishing the mystery.
Time travel.
This is incredible.
Pirates.
Dinosaurs!
Did that rat just drive that car?
This is gonna be interesting.
Ghostwriter’s been preparing
us for this moment.
We’re running out of time.
We went in to the book.
We became book characters?
Stylin’.
This food is so amazing.
Didn’t you eat breakfast this morning?
Yeah, but book eggs taste way better.